here's why flying private is one of the
few things that i spend way too much
money on most things you get used to
over time and you get accustomed to the
luxury and it no longer confers value to
you but i'll tell you there's one thing
that still continues to provide value
independent of how expensive it is that
is flying private flying private is
actually really awesome it's mostly
because it just saves you time and a lot
of energy because you literally just
roll your car up like you're parking at
a store walk into the plane go to where
you're gonna go and there's a car that's
waiting for you right as you get off the
plane with your stuff already packed
literally the only time of travel is the
time that you were in the air and so
what it does is it takes the rest of the
world and brings it closer to you you
can do business you get to where you
want to go you can enjoy your vacations
way better ultimately if you have the
ability to spend it it's one of the few
things that i think is worth the money